welcome to this video playing me to
grindr no meat grinder I'm sorry meat
grinder then I was close mmm let's see
got a Slav him mmm what can I do wanna
do something else here what about g3
this is this is getting popular recently
if he takes the pawn I'm not quite sure
what i'm doing well see that he played a
six so he does not have queen bee six as
a reply that doesn't deter i'm at all no
it's fairly solid follows fairly solid
for black even though the rook looks
funny okay my play here says some way to
use this this look wonder if for a 5mm
don't really have a clear idea what to
do thinking a five and c5 night a4 b6
okay so he prevents that can this i can
i can take on d5 and try to use let's
try that it's actually interesting i can
stick in start with 95 this is maybe
more interesting start with this the
ideas to play see takes if he goes he
takes it takes e4 okay let's try that
because f7 is is a problematic issue for
him let's try that
it's the only way to try to make use of
my current leader development okay but
he i can t gandhi five right this is
this should be a metaphor wide just
winning a spawn they're right or not
should win d 5 at the end here pretty
much whatever he does okay interesting
so i can take e5f right even with the
bishop is not not ridiculous but is
there something else
I mean this is good for either I guess I
don't see how he keeps d5
now if I was the only move to open up
the position trying to exploit them the
better I'm development that i have that
i had so i guess it was the right way to
play Queen d5 takes takes root d1 and
that when did you pawn yeah that also
should win the deep on and it's it's a
nice structure I still have b7 under
fire and Bishop e3 is also quite
annoying so look chicks I guess for the
temple Queen doesn't have really good
squares I mean Roxy 14 I think we need
six maybe mm-hmm okay that's an
interesting question still a look-see
one Queenie six rupee five it's just
good for my time let's do that not think
about it long for long and wait okay
maybe hmm yeah maybe after rugby five he
can take it play Bishop before but
rookie three okay that's okay okay when
he directly went there that's also also
feasible so Bishop e3 now no my rook
McQueen is saying sorry shouldn't do
that so let's start start with taking
shouldn't blunder the Queen that's not
good so let's do it like that and get
the b7 phone
yeah and I'm threatening Luke 12 c 7
okay um so I have I see he wants to play
Bishop f8 but I can go F for here right
you just keep the pawn it's no reason to
give it up I have chief form that cannot
be bad running I know G for traps the
rook yeah let's do that for the exchange
at least so this looks like very nice
control probably just bring the king of
yeah whenever he leaves the yeah and I'm
setting up this pin threatening rugby 8
and its deadly there's nothing that you
can do against them
black resigned yeah it was it was
interesting year right out of the
opening um the thing that I think he was
okay certainly um but I don't know
around here yes to he has to improve
around here he 595 I was thinking maybe
this is an idea I don't know fragile
yeah like Winnie tempo on my queen maybe
this is an idea I can play this but
don't don't think it leads to too much
let's say something like this try to
open up but blackest is very solid you
can also just take keep the end play a
position like that let's not leading to
much but here that that gets it gets a
tantric here with a form yeah it's all
based on on this checkmate this thing of
course so he cannot take with a pawn mmm
the engine stockfish wants to defend
like this 90 x pawn eggs but should be
three and gives white a pretty nice
advantage and this Queen B Sam yeah I'm
just a tad quicker here probably getting
this also later yeah and I'm using but
here here essentially winning yeah 2.5
is quite quite a bit what the engine is
giving what did I had wants to play
differently though interesting i did not
consider that it was to take with the
bishop him okay after night eggs this
Bishop e6 that that's totally totally
gone so um he has to take with this I
see this is what the engine is is up to
it wants to set up appt in there with
rook fu
coming now it's very strong he's in this
in this pin and on the huge pressure
here that's maybe even better than what
would I did yeah Bishop takes was also
not bad maybe better of it it's really
answer choice between a couple of very
very good very good positions and you
are taking the should be three yeah that
that's winning and give I've got two
pawns and I dominate with marks so that
was it was okay okay well thanks for
watching